[Music]
nice might pretend the see creditors
[Music]
I really don't mind if you want that
Hank person or was it Elvis Chuck Berry
all right he's gone he's had it honestly
you can I think it's he's quite quite
what well sort of Mary Chuck Berry what
else and you know bouncy you know I
think you must be the square as person
in all of Western civilization but you
love me
therefore I love you we here married
nothing went wrong even my mother
behaved herself
you set eyes on me for the first time
hello hello
and I saw a man who wasn't wearing a
jacket nonsense
oh yes and trousers with amend and the
knee did you think then it was not so so
now that girl actually I'm a little bit
scared what does his father do you mean
is he working class or one of us that's
more or less what I mean you don't seem
quite as happy as you should something's
bothering you flap come on flow it's
easy just point and choose something
about yourself little delicate but sex
man who says women are like doorways men
can enter through them
got a flirt how long have you been there
I thought I just asked you a question
damn it
they alright I'm feeling rather sick
what is it darling nothing
[Music]
you can change your mind
I really have to go
we can never be happy and it's all my
stupid fault
have you actually forgotten that we were
married today we're man and wife that's
what you promised
turn me
[Music]
it's hopeless is it
[Music]
you